one of the most powerful ways to
increase productivity is to automate in
today's video you'll learn how to set up
a continuous integration and delivery
pipeline for a firebase app using google
cloud build by the end of this video
you'll be able to test build and deploy
your app to firebase by simply
committing your code to github if you're
new here like and subscribe and follow
along with the source code on fire ship
IO you'll find additional pro tips and
pointers in the full write-up so what is
CI CD or DevOps as it's commonly called
it really just boils down to automating
anything and everything that you can
between writing your code and deploying
it to production this results in a whole
wide range of benefits but most
importantly it keeps your development
code as close as possible to your
production code so how does that work
well it starts with a git repo whenever
you commit code to this repo it will
trigger a new build a build is just a
docker container running in the cloud
that does many of the same things that
you would do locally like install your
NPM dependencies test build and deploy
to firebase this is exactly what we do
for fire ship IO in addition to other
things like updating our search index on
algo Lea etc if the build fails at any
step it will not deploy the final code
and we'll know exactly where the problem
lies and cloud build will give us
detailed blogs that we can hopefully use
to find the root of the problem so
getting all this stuff set up is kind of
painful in the beginning but once you
have it set up you'll be very glad that
you did for a fighter ship IO it pushes
new code and content to the site almost
every day and even as an independent
developer that saves me a ton of time
but just imagine how much time that
would save a large team the adoption of
C ICD has been kind of a macro trend for
the last few years and there's a lot of
really good services out there like
Travis and circle so what are the
advantages of Google cloud build the
first obvious one is pricing it offers a
hundred and twenty minutes of free build
time per day which is probably way more
than you need but if you exceed it
becomes pay-as-you-go after that other
CI services generally have a free tier
but then it becomes a monthly fee after
that which is usually over 50 bucks a
month and because it's integrated with
GCP it's really easy to connect other
services for example we can just add I
am permissions to deploy to firebase
hosting in this video I'll show you how
to work with I am but I'll also show you
how to encrypt your environment if you
want to use tokens from external
services which is required by a large
number of apps
to get started you can use any front-end
that you want it can be angular or view
or react or whatever then you'll also
need a firebase project which
automatically comes with a Google Cloud
project and then you'll need to install
the g-cloud command line tools from
there you'll need some kind of front-end
app in this case I'm just generating a
VJ s app the only real requirement is
that it's a JavaScript app using NPM and
it should have scripts that we can
automate like a testing script and a
build script from there I'm going to
initialize firebase in this project in
this demo we'll only be using hosting
but you could also use this to deploy
your cloud functions as well so I've
just made some slight modifications to
the default view app and this is what we
want to deploy automatically the next
step is to set up a git repo we could
use cloud source repositories on GCP but
in this case we'll be using github
bitbucket is also an option go ahead and
create the repo and then push some
initial code to it then in the command
line we'll just run a git add git commit
and we'll connect our local code to the
remote repository you can see those
commands on the github repo itself so
just copy and paste those and then we
should be good to go now I'm going to
show you two different ways to configure
firebase with cloud build the first one
is very simple by just configuring I am
roles and the second one will actually
configure a fully encrypted environment
that you can use to also encrypt other
third party API is like say algo Lea
SendGrid
etc so let's start by enabling cloud
build on GCP after that go to the IM
page which stands for identity access
management you'll see the service
account for cloud build and by default
it doesn't have access to our firebase
project we can do that by editing the
permissions and adding a role for
firebase admin as well as the API keys
admin and optionally you can add the kms
crypto key decryptor but that one's only
needed if you use the encrypted
environment that I'll show you towards
the end of this video so now that we
have our permission set up we need to
tell cloud build the actual steps
involved in building testing and
deploying our app in order to do that in
the cloud we need to have some sort of
execution environment which we do with
docker containers these are called
builder images and they just give you
access to very common commands like the
NPM command or git go etc but you'll
notice that the firebase command is
missing from this list if the command
you need is missing from that list
you'll want to go to the community
maintain builders repo this is where we
can find that firebase builder and what
we want to do is clone this repo and
then deploy our own
image to our GCP project this is
actually really easy we just clone the
repo
then we CD into the firebase directory
and then we'll run g-cloud build submit
and this will save the image to the
container registry on our GCP project so
this allows us to run the firebase
deploy command and have the right
permissions context that we set up in IM
you can verify that that works by going
to the container registry on GCP and you
should see the image there from there
you can just go ahead and delete the
community builders repo from your local
system if you want to clean things up
now we're to the fun part where we
actually get to define our CI CD
pipeline create a cloud build Yamma file
in the root of the project it contains
an array of steps where each step is a
part of your build process you'll notice
the first property is a name which
points to the actual command that you
want to run and then orgs is an array of
whatever you want to add to that command
so in this case it's like running npm
install in this view app we have four
steps first we run npm install then we
run our unit tests then we run npm build
and you'll notice for all those steps we
use the built in npm cloud builder but
for our deploy step we're actually using
our firebase container so we pass in an
environment variable for the project ID
slash firebase and keep in mind there's
a whole bunch different options you can
pass these steps to customize the way
they behave so that defines our build
the next step is to tell GCP to listen
to our github repository so go to the
create trigger tab and then click github
and then choose your repo from the list
and also keep in mind that GCP has a
plugin that you can install directly in
github to do this stuff automatically
but it's fairly limited at this point so
i want to show you that full process you
can trigger your build on different
branches or tags and for now we're just
going to keep it simple and trigger it
on everything that's good for testing
your code but you probably don't want to
deploy on anything but the master branch
so check out the full article I have
some code that shows you how to do that
and also make sure to tell it to use the
cloud build yamo file and not a docker
file now it's time for the moment of
truth create another git commit and then
run git push origin master to push it to
github and then you should see the build
run automatically in the cloud build
page for an app like this it should only
take a minute or two and it will log out
everything that's going on directly in
the console it's pretty common to get
errors at this point so if you
you make sure to check the logs and it
should tell you exactly what went wrong
but hopefully you see all green and when
you go to the actual URL you see your
final deployed production code and keep
in mind if you do run into problems you
can always submit builds directly from
the command line or directly from the
console so you don't have to always
commit your code to get just to trigger
a build now the next thing I want to
show you is a little more advanced and
that's how to create an encrypted
environment for your build in this
example we're not going to rely on the I
M permissions but instead use the
firebase CI token this approach has the
advantage of being able to scale to
other secrets or API keys in your
environment and it also means we don't
need to use that firebase builder image
so you can skip that step if you want to
go this route install firebase tools in
your development environment then run
firebase log and CI that will give you a
token that you can use to authenticate
the cloud build server for your project
from there create a env file this is
where we'll save all of our environment
variables and keep in mind you'll have
sensitive secrets in here so you don't
want to expose this in a public get repo
or any other public format now that we
have our token we'll go ahead and define
a new deploy script in that package JSON
file it just runs firebase deploy and
then we'll pass in the token option and
point it to that environment variable at
this point we need a secure way to get
our local secrets to our CI server will
do this by encoding them with a
cryptographic key this means we'll be
able to put our encrypted secrets in a
public get repo but only services that
have the proper permission will be able
to decode them the first thing I want to
do is create a keyring we'll call it my
project and it's able to hold multiple
keys or multiple encrypted files in a
single context in our case we want to
encrypt the entire environment file so
we'll give that key a name of cloud
build env then we can just keep the
default options for everything else from
there we'll go back to our project and
we'll run g-cloud KMS encrypt we're
telling it to encrypt our local
environment file as a new file called
env ENC this file is encrypted so it's
perfectly fine to put in your git repo
now we need to update our cloud build
file the first thing we want to do is
decrypt our environment secrets because
cloud build has access to the crypto key
decryptor I am role it can use that env
file just like we would locally
so it has access to all of the same
environment variables that we do
currently that's just the firebase token
but in a larger project you'll probably
have multiple third-party API is that
you need to manage the other change we
want to make is take out the firebase
deploy command in favor of the NPM run
deploy command go ahead and commit these
changes to github and you should see a
new build populate and if you go into
firebase hosting you should now see
cloud build as the service account
running the deployments so hopefully
this showed you that automation is
pretty awesome and make sure to grab the
full article from fire ship IO to just
copy and paste all these commands leave
me a comment if you have any questions
or feedback thanks for watching and I
will talk to you soon